Speaker 1: All right. Let's get into Friday
feedback. So many different messages coming in,
continuing for all sorts of different reasons.
And I want to have an opportunity here to go
over some stuff with people in the audience. One
of the things that I love about my audience is you
all don't forget about gun safety just because
it's been like a little while since the last
major mass shooting. Now in the United States, we
have individual shootings, we have mass shootings,
and then we have major mass shootings. Major
means like it actually makes national headlines.
It's a crazy country where we actually have mass
shootings every day, but most of them don't make
national headlines. Okay. You all keep your eye
on the ball even when there hasn't been a major
national mass shooting for a little bit. Here's a
very interesting YouTube comment, which is, David,
as a law abiding citizen who owns several firearms
that I use for sport, shooting and hunting,
there's something no one has been able to explain
to me. How is it that the federal government can
implement and enforce a national ban on fully
automatic weapons and sawed off shotguns but is
unable to do the same for semiautomatic firearms?
Seems to me that every mass shooting in recent
history has involved a semiautomatic firearm. A
ban on semiautomatic firearms would not violate
the Second Amendment, and, as a matter of fact,
could be argued that it speaks directly to the
well-regulated militia aspect of the Second
Amendment. What are your thoughts? Well, the
answer is, of course, you could ban semiautomatic
weapons, but there isn't congressional support to
do it. This I'm not going to pretend that I can
cite every law on which the current status quo
is based. Okay. That that I'm making that very,
very clear. But the National Firearms Act of 1934
is very much, if not the only reason. Again, I
want to defer a little bit to possibility. It
is a huge part of the reason why fully automatic
machine guns are not legal and it's because of
how they are classified. And it goes back to the
National Firearms Act of 1934 and other elements
of law. There have been votes in the House of
Representatives as to whether to ban semiautomatic
weapons as well. But these votes have not
succeeded at a time when you could also get a vote
to succeed in the Senate and have it signed by the
president. This is absolutely something that could
be done. As this viewer points out, it wouldn't
violate the Second Amendment. No, it's just a
matter of where we draw the line. Do we we most
people agree that shoulder mounted RPGs are on the
banned side and should be not not they agree. They
are they agree they should be on the banned side.
We have the National Firearms Act of 1934 when it
comes to fully automatic machine guns. It's just a
matter of where we draw the line. The answer
for why semiautomatic weapons aren't banned
is that they there is not the political
will to actually do it. It's that simple.
And I don't know, maybe it will change. But you're
absolutely correct that a disproportionate number
of these major mass shootings are committed
at the hands of such a semiautomatic weapon.
Scott commented on YouTube, says, David, I've
been watching on your been watching your content
for a couple of years. Love what you do. Love
your presentation style and the way you do. You
think about things. You help me to craft my own
ideas about how to engage with my Trumpster dad
and still allow room for grace knowing he has
been brainwashed by Fox. That said, I hope you
weather this storm. I'm in Georgia. I'm a retired
20 year U.S. Army infantry senior NCO. I am a
combat veteran of Iraq and Afghanistan. I don't
really know if it's even possible or helpful,
but if there is anything I can do to provide for
you and your loved ones protection and safety, I
would do it for free. Well, I might ask for a dry
place to sleep and food if it's too far from home.
Thank you, sir, and thank you for your service.
And we are weathering the storm. You know, it is
upsetting to many of the in the hate mob. I know
they're furious because they keep writing to me.
They really thought they were going to get me
canceled over the tweet from now a couple of weeks
ago. They really did. And they saw that we came
out of it with tens of thousands more YouTube
subscribers and the website generated over a
thousand new paid subscribers and messages of
support from celebrities and elected officials.
And less than anyone with half a brain knows
what I'm talking about. Anyone with half a brain
knows I'm not going to blame kids who were killed
for being killed. We blame our elected officials
and we blame the shooters. That's who we blame
and aspects of the society that have gone wrong.
But I really appreciate that. And we are getting
through it. And it's been crazy, but we are doing
what we can. Jack commented on YouTube and said,
I used to be a conservative. I switched because
of people like Pacman and Kyle Kalinsky Keep
doing what you're doing right now. Now, David,
they only hate the tweet because you are 100%
correct. Conservatives are more angry over your
tweet than they are that kids were murdered. It's
a useful distraction. If you're mad at me and
some of them still are, if you're mad at me.
You don't have to talk about the fact that
you don't want to do a damn thing about guns.
One other message along these lines, this one
from Scott. This one might be fake. It's funny,
though. It might be real. I used to be a
conservative for over 40 years. Pacman changed
that. Trump changed that. I put in the paperwork
to become a Democrat, and I've never been happier.
I even lost weight hanging around left wingers.
You know, this may be a joke. I genuinely don't
know. What's so funny about it is obesity is
dramatically higher in red states. I mean,
it's not about make everything political. There
was recently a study about life expectancy at
birth in the deep blue areas of the country and
the deep red areas of the country. Obviously, you
have to take economics into account. Big, big part
of this, But you are likely to live much longer.
If you are born and live in blue areas, it's it
is an incredible thing that we have going on in
this country where political allegiance and
the allegiance of state government has such
an impact on every aspect of our lives. Really
incredible stuff. Raymond emailed me and said,
Just a comment from an average Joe. I think this
is super interesting and also very depressing.
Raymond said was just watching Friday feedback and
heard your advice about debating people online.
I'm pretty good at it, probably because I'm 64.
I've been a politics junkie since age 16. Used
to skip school so I could stay home and watch the
Watergate hearings. In the last two years, I've
debated at least 40 magazines into silence. I set
traps for them by writing things I know they'll
agree with, and then pointing out how the some
of those beliefs add up to the opposite of the
point they're trying to make. Then they go quiet.
They'll never admit it, and they'll never admit
I'm right in the moment. But their silence signals
their capitulation. But then it occurred to me,
there are 70 million more of them out there,
and suddenly those victories feel pretty
hollow. It's demoralizing. This one hits,
guys. This one hits. As I've said before,
we can spend hours trying to show these people the
errors in their ways. And sometimes will succeed.
And then you remember 70 million people voted for
Trump and you realize what we are up against. So
an inspiring message from Raymond in the sense
that he he has clearly figured out a way to do it.
But then you remember there's 70 million of
them. And then? Then what? Then where do we
go? This is the whole retail versus wholesale
strategy thing that's often discussed. The ways
to achieve rapid social change often
are to enforce them via dictatorship,
which I'm against. I know Trump's enamored
with all these dictators, but I'm not.
So then you say, Well, then how do you do it? And
it is very slow change over long periods of time,
focusing on education, focusing on media
literacy, extremely, extremely difficult to do.
Daniel wrote in and says, I'm evil. This is still
like the sort of stuff that's coming in. Based on
the tweet from a couple weeks ago, Daniel says,
David, you are evil. I saw the tweet you mocked
murdered Christian children. I am sorry for
you. Your parents failed and you are troubled
on the inside may somehow you find peace. Your
hatred must be a serious burden. Yeah. No,
that's not really it. I am disgusted by our
elected officials who send thoughts and prayers
and do nothing else. That's basically it. It's
not about evil. It's not about troubled. It's not
about finding peace. It's not about any of it. But
these folks won't stop, guys. They keep emailing.
Here's George. All right. This is something I
think you guys are going to enjoy. George wrote
in and said, David, considering how small the
trans population is worldwide, why do you spend
so much time covering trans issues? Please tell
me how to cancel my membership. Thank you, George.
Um, I've told you guys before about what I call
unsubscribe trolls. These are people who write
to me and they say, David, I was just about
to become a page member. And then you said X,
and now I'm not going to. David, I've been a
subscriber for five years, But now that you said
Y I'm canceling. I looked up George. George was
last a member in 2020 and since 2020, this is why,
why we file all of our messages. Sometimes law
enforcement needs them. But this is another reason
why, since 2020, George has written to me 16 times
saying he's going to cancel his membership because
I said X and then because I said, Why? And then
because I said Z. In fact, when I look this up.
It's like, who has time to do this stuff? George
wrote to me back in November. And said, You're not
talking about the CCP enough. I'm canceling. And
then George wrote to me. And so there's so many
of these. It's hard to find all of them. Uh Oh,
God. When was this? George wrote to me in May.
And said they need to do something about of smart
fencing at schools and you're not talking about
it and I'm going to cancel. Okay. The point
here is. George has written to me 16 times
saying he's going to cancel since he was last a
member. Folks, I've said it before and I'll say
it again. The freedom that I get from being
supported by individual members is that no
one person can come in and tell me, cover this
or don't cover it or whatever the case may be.
That's a great thing. And I will continue covering
what I think makes sense. Why am I covering the
trans issue more than the prevalence of trans
people in the population? Very good question.
The reason is because the American right wing
has now started devoting way too much of their
time to making the lives of trans people a living
hell. And so when I see a group being targeted.
Unfairly, I come to their defense. As soon as the
mob leaves transpeople alone, I will be able to
move away from that issue. So that's why. George.
All right, my friend. Best of luck with all of it.
Send in your emails info at David Pakman dot
com YouTube comment, tweet Facebook. We pull
these from all over the place and yours might
be featured next week. Fantastic bonus show
for you today. Sign up at join pacman dot
com. Don't miss it. Extraordinary stuff.